can tell you well Brigadier General Pat
writer has been on his feet there has
been activity elsewhere specifically in
a place called North Titan Massachusetts
a suspect has been arrested in
connection with the leaking of
classified material around half a dozen
FBI agents with rifles entered a
property and a suspect was seen to be
led away from that property frog marched
arms behind his back by what appeared to
be FBI agents we're expecting a news
conference imminently by America's
attorney general Merrick Garland he is
the man in overall charge of
prosecutions in the United States and
you heard Pat Rider referring to the
Department of Justice well the doj will
have it see on the matter at which stage
we will know further detail on what
happened in the past half hour but as I
say an arrest has been made by FBI
agents in Massachusetts and you'll
remember that 21 year old Jack took Sira
was Massachusetts based this a young
National Guardsman an Airman and you can
see the scene there are some police
vehicles just outside a property and
what appears to be a fairly quiet
Suburban Street there are media on site
and I might say there have been media on
site for several hours several hours
before these FBI agents turned up and
perhaps that is a question that feeds
into all of this why and the final
moments that the media get to the
suspect before FBI agents why did the
media get to the documents before the
FBI agents and why have these documents
been in widespread public circulation on
the internet
for more than a year all sorts of
questions to be answered
none I have to say really take it on
directly by Brigadier General Pat Ryder
at the Pentagon he was in a position
where he was able to bat away the the
difficult questions you know he's a
Smooth Operator given a rough ride by
journalists at that news conference his
answer to the business of security
appeared to be consistently and
repeatedly we have strict protocols in
place I think the questioning wasn't
answered it was all that's fine but what
about when you have a bad actor in the
building how are they policed and what
what is the mechanism whereby when
somebody steals something you hunt them
down he gave the comparison of somebody
in
breaking into your house and retrieving
a bag I suppose the answer to his answer
is well it wouldn't take more than a
year to chase the Border who took your
bag why have you taken longer than a
year to retrieve National sensitive
government secrets and why have you
taken more than a year to arrest the
individual responsible but an arrest has
been made as we look at that scene
uh
you see police vehicles mounting the
site in the past minutes there have been
FBI agents A with body armor armed
entering a property and making an arrest
as I say of a suspect who is now in
custody